(upbeat music)
- It's now time for
tonight's hash tag wars.
(audience screams)
(bell dings)
- [Chris] Michelle.
- Lost the Baby Spice.
- Yes, points.
Dave Hill.
- La la chlamydia.
(audience screams)
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Michelle.
- Salt and Pooper's here.
- Yes, good points.
Aw, push it.
Steve.
- Chode the wet sprocket.
- [Chris] Yeah, Chode the wet sprocket.
Sure, points.
Dave.
- Okay looking woman.
- Oh, yeah.
Sure.
Yeah.
(audience screams)
- [Chris] No, no.
Come back, come back!
(upbeat music)
- Jimmy.
- Men In Blacked Out.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience screams)
Well done.
- Riggle.
- Fartacus.
- Yes, points.
Cube.
- James Bong.
(audience screams)
- Yes, points.
(ding)
- [Chris] Yes, Rob.
- How to Drain Your Dragon.
(audience screams)
- [Chris] Points.
(ding)
Ice Cube.
- Die Hard of Alcohol Poisoning.
- Yes, you have to be careful.
That's a public service
message from Ice Cube.
The more you know.
Yes, Ice Cube.
- 22 Jump Him.
- [Chris] Yes.
Yeah, good.
Well played, well played.
Riggle.
- Panty raiders of the lost ark.
(audience screams)
- Yes. So good.
(ding)
- [Chris] Ice Cube.
- Girls Gone Wild Interrupted.
- [Chris] Yes.
(ding)
Tommy Johnagin.
- Justin Beiber is singing
all the national anthems.
(audience laughing)
- Points.
Jackie.
- That Is the Cup of a Carpenter.
- Yes oh Indiana Jones
and the Last Crusade.
Points.
Bamford.
- In Europe it's not called soccer,
it's called rioting.
- Points.
Yeah points good.
Nice job.
It is.
Tommy.
- Germany's team is made
up of all openly gay men.
- Points.
Yeah.
Jackie.
- No human heads were really used.
- Points.
Bamford.
- Brazil is safe.
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Jimmy Pardo.
- Cialis Cooper.
- Yes wonderful points.
Jimmy Pardo.
- Mumford.
(audience laughs)
- Well played, points.
(ding)
Ali Wong.
- Nat King Colonoscopy.
- Yes, good one.
That would definitely be unforgettable.
Jimmy Pardo.
- Stevie Ray Vaughan mower.
- [Chris] Yes good points.
Jimmy Pardo!
- Is my button even working?
- No it's not.
I came to play baby.
Dinosaur Senior.
- [Chris] Yes good points.
Ian.
- Pat Boon Bone Thugs N Harmony.
- Yes good.
Good. Points.
Ali.
- The Rolling Kidney Stones.
- Yup.
Points.
Ian Edwards.
- If I can get my hands on the kids
who keep smashing those pumpkins.
- Yes. Points!